okay I guess we're live good all right
so at this point I want to talk a little
bit about protein interaction networks
where we get the data come from
particularly but I was trying to be more
general in the first part although I
kept drifting into protein interaction
networks which is where we're gonna be
going for most of the rest of today but
I want to start by telling you a little
about where the data come from and why
we care and then talk about some
function prediction approaches and why
we care about that as well and how we do
that
so specifically talking about protein
interaction networks right so we've seen
the proteins can bind to each other a
lot of protein interactions is there
there are different kinds of protein
interactions so some of them will be
sort of stable interactions that form
part of a complex where a bunch of
proteins get together and stay together
and do something for a while others are
more transient and they tend to be
involved in responding to particular
cellular situations or so for example
this is a signaling response to
adrenaline g-protein signaling in
response to adrenaline so a receptor
binds to that which in turn comes in
changes the this is a g-protein that's
got two different subunits bound
together when this thing gets in there
changes the conformation of this
releases GDP attracts GTP and that
allows it to bind to something else and
in amplify that signal and pass that
along in the cell right so these are
kind of transient interactions in
response to a particular stimulus and
this is how the cell functions and
passes information along and how it
responds to things actually
that works right so in this field we
really like to talk about protein
interaction networks and maybe the first
question is why do we care right and the
reason we care is because they can tell
us about things that we care about right
we care about protein function we care
about protein function in particular
well I don't know I do a lot of work in
humans so I care about when proteins are
functioning properly and when they're
not and how that leads to disease if we
know about function we can begin this is
- and how it relates to disease we can
begin to suggest avenues for developing
new therapeutics new treatments I
actually worked for the pharmaceutical
company Wyeth for a bunch of years so
like I'm was intimately involved in
trying to find intelligent and develop
intelligent targeted therapies and of
course we can even try to infer what the
interaction network looks like when we
don't have raw data about that so
basically we get excited because we're
we're computer scientists but we can use
this to do biology and do mattis medical
research and in particular we have lots
of data to work with and so this gives
us the ability to do things so I put
this picture up because I think of
protein interaction networks is really a
bridge between sort of computational
models and function and we're going to
be spending some time on that bridge
looking on how to get there
and of course I have to pick this bridge
because we're here right so there are a
lot of different methods now for
generating high-throughput protein
interaction data and I'm gonna just talk
about a couple of them you know looking
last week at what's been done since most
of the big papers came out there are 15
new methods all of which are variations
on a theme but the bulk of the data I
think is still from these two families
of approaches I should say and this is
sort of a nice temporal model of where
big data sets of different organisms and
you can see funny looking humans and
funny-looking mice came out over time
it needs to be updated now but gives you
a sense of like growing datasets and the
size of the datasets our log scale on
the y-axis so briefly the basic idea of
yeast two-hybrid s is is to use the
cells own machinery to tell you about
protein interactions its own
transcriptional machinery and so the
idea is we build a construct we have a
DNA binding dump that is not what I
wanted
so we have a DNA binding domain here and
in order to transcribe this particular
gene we need the DNA binding domain and
the DNA activation de transcriptional
activation domain to be in close
proximity to each other so we create a
bait fusion protein that has the protein
or the proteins whose interactions we
want to study the which we call the bait
or X we fuse that to this DNA binding
domain and then we fuse an activation
domain to candidate interactors we'll
call Y and we call that the prey and
when x and y bind to each other if they
are able to bind to each other we get
transcription basically the activation
domain recruits RNA polymerase 2 and we
get transcription of a reporter gene
this is usually Lac Z or something where
you can actually look at it and see a
color change indicating that you've got
transcription right so this is a bait
and pray system where you can look for
pairwise interactions and so this is
something that scales up very nicely
one of the advantages of this is that
because you can do it in a cellular
context and you can do it you can use it
to capture potential interactions that
may not occur all the time you can put
two proteins together and if they are
you know have sufficient affinity for
each other and the conditions are right
they will bind to each other and you'll
see this even if it's something that you
would normally have to look you know in
vivo at a lot of different conditions
for their nice binary interactions so if
we like our graph formalism then this is
a good fit for that
you know it's very scalable but it does
have a number of drawbacks right so we
do this in a very controlled cellular
environment it's not necessarily in
cells from the organism you care about
in fact it's you cell kind of regardless
of what you're looking at and so it
doesn't have the contextual signals that
say this interaction should occur right
if it's an interaction that signals
response to adrenaline rate we're not in
a condition where we're responding to
adrenaline and so some of the other
things that may be going on in your
cellular context are missing the big one
really is that just because I can put
two proteins together and force them to
bind to each other in this assay does
not mean that they are ever made at the
same time in the same part of the cell
in real life right so we get lots of
false positives from things that could
interact but don't and we get false
negatives from other interactions right
so they're there they can miss things
you don't see complexes groups of
proteins that may be binding to you
right what if you get you know protein a
can only bind to proteins B and C
together you're not gonna see that so
there's a lot of noise in these things
and it also actually depends on who you
choose as the bait and who you choose as
the prey as to which directly which
kinds of noise you get and so there's
you know higher confidence in an
interaction where you've seen it from
both directions then if you've seen it
from just one direction right so other
approaches that use something related to
immuno precipitation or a wider family
of things that I'll just called affinity
and pulldown methods that are there
there are a number of different ways of
doing this but they're all sort of
variations on the following theme where
we have in this case an antibody right
it's a basic immuno precipitation we
have an antibody that binds to an
antigen particular protein and if we can
use some kind of tag to identify this
antibody and pull it out and then break
break those bonds and break them
part we can try and figure out what this
protein is so in Co IP which is really
what we use for find interactions we do
the same thing with the target protein
like an antigen and a complex that it's
part of and we can put this into a
cellular context and it pulls down the
protein complex and then we break this
apart and we actually use mass spec or
some variant on it to try to identify
what the component proteins in that
complex are right so we break them apart
into different and into their individual
components and then we get a spectral
analysis of what they look like and
that's in charge and we try to figure
out what we've got so again this has
sort of different interment advantages
in particular it's designed to pull out
complexes right now these approaches
will get things a whole bunch of
proteins are bound together you get more
context because you can work in the
original context and if you want to
again if you want to increase
reliability you can use different
proteins as the antigen or the bait in
this case but you're still missing stuff
right so now it's because we're looking
at what's present in a particular time
we have the problem we had before where
the transient interactions we might not
see the tags that we need to produce in
some form to pull the antibodies out can
potentially interfere with complex
information binding right so we get
false negatives we get false positives
and we're not you know mass spec is
really good but it's not perfect great
so we may not actually recognize what is
in our soup of proteins that that bound
together initially accurately and we
also have a problem of interpretation so
all we get out from picture of a protein
complex is here are the components of
the protein complex so now that we're
trying to build our binary
representation we have a couple of
options right so here's my betas in blue
and my prey
or in lighter blue how do we want to
represent it I have a whole bunch of
players so I can do a sort of spoke
model where I have connections to
pairwise connections to each individual
player but they don't talk to each other
or I could do something that gives you a
complete graph and I don't know that
either of those is right and probably
the right answer is somewhere in between
right so we're working with extremely
noisy data under the best of
circumstances I'm gonna talk about
mostly just this I'm not gonna go into
detail about how we infer these but so
experimentally we'd still like to be
able to identify a larger range of
protein-protein interactions than we've
actually got from high throughput
experiments where people did these kinds
of things and there are lots of ways of
doing this one of the best sources of
data on really everything in biology is
the biomedical literature right so you'd
say okay this is great people have done
a study that actually demonstrated not
in a high-throughput assay but in you
know a mouse that protein a does really
in vivo interact with protein B that's
great data and that's reliable data but
capturing that through text mining is
painful and let me just point out that
I've done a little bit of work in the
field of biomedical text mining the
problem of figuring out where in even in
just an abstract of a paper somebody is
referring to a protein and what protein
they're talking about is really really
hard and we have contests like there's
the bio creative contest to figure out
if you can do this better than other
people and it's it's you know we can get
a certain percentage of the way there
but that last 20-30 percent is really
hard complicated by the fact that some
communities like the fruit fly people
give their proteins really silly names
so
you know and their their names that
could be English words that would be
perfectly normal in text so it's really
hard to figure some of this out um a
great way of doing this is structural
right so if you actually have 3d
structure of two proteins you can start
to make predictions about how they might
bind to each other and this is
potentially effective but it's actually
hard right first of all because we don't
have the solid structures of most
proteins and our ability to predict
structure is again another one of these
hard problems that's kind of plateauing
not quite all the way we need to be to
the solution and partially because we
just don't do a great job of predicting
interaction from structure but weird you
know so if if you have good structures
you can try to do this we do it with
moderate accuracy co-expression I hate
to have to put this on here but a lot of
the databases predict the two proteins
interact if they are expressed in the
same place that is really overly
optimistic if you have a very high
threshold for Co expression it might be
reasonable if you have a context
specific threshold for Co expression it
might be reasonable I tend to look for
this data in large-scale data sets and
filter it out or be very careful using
it but you really want to know if it's
in there
and then there's the question of
predicting interactions from sequence
ontology so this is getting back to what
we were talking about if we have an
evolutionary process you duplicate some
proteins and maybe it diverges over time
but can't you just assume that if you
know the proteins are homologous and the
previous organism and the ancestral
organism they're then they're
interacting with each other now right
and so this is the concept called
Tara logs so basically briefly speaking
if we have two proteins that were
derived from a common ancestor then we
say there are thalamus and all right so
now we have you know modern species and
B we have the same the same gene or the
same protein and they derive from a
common ancestor so we'll call them
orthologues right so suppose we have two
pairs of orthologues
Jean Juan and Jean - in these different
species and we know that protein in
species a these proteins interact can we
just assume that they interact in
species B and if we can we would call
them in Terrell logs I don't know this
is the ohmic izing of the English
language or something
so can we assume in Terrell logs are
there the answer is yeah maybe so yes
sometimes but much less than you'd think
right this is actually a paper of
requests from a number of years ago but
there's a lot of supporting data as well
from other people not as much as you
think and the conservation of
interaction is proportional to how
similar the sequences of these orthologs
and these orthologs are and they have to
be really highly similar so forget like
vague structural similarity they have to
be quite highly conserved before you can
conclude that you can map this
interaction to this species with any
confidence and they also argued that
with duplications you can you can do
this better within a species then across
species like the threshold you can you
can take a lower threshold for sequence
similarity and believe that the
interaction still holds if you're in the
same species but once you're in a new
organism there's too much other stuff
going on basically that interferes with
it and so you need a much higher
threshold for sequence similarity to
believe then Tara logs are real so this
is just something you need to be aware
of is that you know people do this but
you've got to be careful about it but
you know you can also look at larger
things and I'll let her then talk about
this kind of stuff but if you look at
wider of neighborhoods than just the
immediate structure of a pairwise
interaction you may be able to recover
some information that lets you predict
other interactions the other thing to
notice is that degree correlation is not
great it's so even if you have orthologs
to orthologues in different species
the correlation of their degrees is kind
of you know numerically is kind of low
but it still turns out that if we have
hugs that have important regulatory
functions highly connected nodes even
though there isn't a direct you don't
see a line out here but as a proportion
of Carl there's correlation of degree of
homologous nodes in two species I think
it's apply in worm but all of the plots
pretty much look like this you can still
find that they're likely to be highly
connected but individual connections
will get gained and lost all over the
place
right
yes so right so part of the question is
if you do this as a proportion of the
total number of edges you know you it
still kind of looks like this but you
get a little bit more conservation up
out in the area that you were you'd
expect correlation so yes it's yes the
missing data thing rears its head again
right and and you want to we were trying
to pick that the time then networks that
we had the best data for but you're
right they're all incomplete and they're
incomplete in different ways
right so where do you get this data from
I felt like I should mention there are a
whole bunch of databases mostly I just
wanted to put some of them on a slide so
if you're looking at this later you want
to go get some data you have some
starting points for where to look and
the other question is where where do you
find data about exactly the kinds of
things you're talking about right so
there's noise there's well missing data
and people have looked at false positive
and false negative reads the upshot is
they're high but they're variable from
data set to data set and from person
assessing it the person assessing it and
so it depends on how you exactly measure
and I don't have a particular method
that I'm going to promote here but most
of the people doing the experiment can
at least give you something of an
assessment of how much they believe that
particular interaction occurs and so the
most of the databases now will collect
confidence scores on individual edges
and those are useful things to have and
if you have a whole bunch of people who
predict the same interaction with
probability 0.8 or something then maybe
it's a cumulative probability goes up
right so you can begin to get better
better reliability and you're right that
this is the question you were asking is
what about all the stuff that's missing
so here's a protein interaction Network
neighborhood of a particular node and
confidence scores on the edges and
this isn't really the picture when you
when you view a graph like this you're
really talking about this graph right
it's a complete graph with nodes that
you didn't know about and edges that you
didn't know about and you don't know
what the probabilities are on those
except that either they haven't been
assigned yet or they have been but they
didn't work or maybe they maybe they
have been and they predicted no
interaction and that's correct and you
don't you need to come up with some
estimate for what the probabilities are
for all those other edges so they have
to kind of be in the back of your mind
when you're thinking about these graphs
I do see a lot of papers submitted where
people just don't think about confidence
they don't think about reliability they
don't think about missing data and they
those papers don't tend to get very far
so and they don't tend to have realistic
conclusions
the
other thing I just wanted to mention
again briefly is that sometimes you can
get useful information by visualizing
parts of the network doing this is hard
a lot of people in our community like to
use Site escape which is you know trades
open-source tool that has begun to
become much bigger than that and that
has a lot of support built in for
biomedical networks in particular
Jeffie is getting very popular as a
network visualization tool I'm seeing a
number of papers and it is more
generally sort of aimed at the the you
know graphs and networks community and
all around it has a lot of nice built-in
functions but neither of these do a
great job of visualizing large protein
interaction networks which typically
look like this and this has become such
a joke that in fact people make fun of
it so here's the is M bingo card and one
of the points is for a talk that has a
ridiculous a grammar in other words one
of those graphs of protein interaction
networks so try to be careful when
you're working with these like
visualization is useful for your own
purposes but putting up pictures of
stars is not helpful
the card is really good I have the rest
of it of people on it all right so now I
want to talk a little and talk about how
we get function out of all of this and
the first question about that is really
what is how do we know about function
how do it right so genes and proteins do
things how do we know that somebody does
an experiment right somebody does
something in cells or the yeast and they
write about it
they write about it in natural language
and all of a sudden we're back to this
problem I mentioned earlier which is
that you know natural language
processing is a hard sub to computer
science that probably not that many of
us work in some of us may and biomedical
natural language processing is a harder
subfield science or at least it's it's a
specific one right so a lot of the
general natural language processors that
are trained on corpora from the Wall
Street Journal do a really dismal job
reading biomedical papers and I'm sure
any of you who have spent five minutes
with PubMed will understand why right
though the use of language is very very
different not just because we can't find
proteins or the gene names but we can't
find the interaction types we can't find
the experimental evidence we can't find
the regulator not which is three
sentences back and kind of important if
we're saying these things do perform a
function or do not perform a function so
we have we have a hard time getting this
information automatically but if we want
to do anything about function prediction
that uses a computer we need
representation of protein function that
computers can deal with and free text
isn't it so we actually need a
dictionary that characterizes protein
function in some canonical way and
probably the best known and best used in
you know maybe most solid of these is
the gene ontology and this is basically
an organization of people who recognize
this problem 15 years ago and said you
know we really need to do something
about standardizing functional
annotation for genes and gene products
across organisms and in a way that can
be computationally useful so the
annotation there's actually an ontology
that they've developed that's
continually evolving it's represented as
a directed acyclic graph so terms you
know there are more general terms at the
top and more specific terms at the
bottom and you can they can inherit from
multiple parents if
they're sort of examples of actually so
there are colors of edges basically
saying are they examples of or they
regulated by are they doing what are
they part of a process and there
actually are three ontology really so
one that captures what they call
biological processes like you know
development for limb development one
that captures molecular function often
enzymatic function and one that's really
based on where in the cell things are
and that sometimes is a clue to what
they're doing right so a lot of the
annotations are actually in this
cellular component ontology like we know
that this is a membrane protein because
it has a structural motif that makes you
think it's a membrane protein we have no
idea what it does right so that's that's
a good chunk of what's in there
but there's of course a lot of more
functionally specific data and again
this is because this is designed to be
standardized there's information about
so basically this data comes from papers
and it comes from somebody doing
experiment writing a paper somebody else
reading it or in some cases
computationally assisted reading it
computer says read this but the human
usually checks it there's there is an
evidence code for just computationally
inferred evidence and most people are
worried about using that because that's
pretty noisy because we don't do
national language well and we don't do
you know co-expression doesn't mean that
something does you know so the
conclusions are more likely to be wrong
in those cases for those of you who are
pis here who know about the gene
ontology and can't imagine life without
it their grant is up for renewal if you
had time in the next couple of days to
write a support letter if you can't
imagine them not getting funding again
then talk to me because they're
collecting letters and this is a good
thing to do disclosure is I'm on the
scientific advisory board of the go now
so so they do a lot of different species
and one of the things you'll notice is
that right they distinguish between
experimentally derived and
computationally derived stuff
and are represented in many species
especially model organisms like nelson
rat some of the others that were in you
know fly and worm and zebrafish are also
very actively involved so when we talk
about functional annotations and go we
can say due to proteins have the same
annotation term but now we're getting
into trouble again because let's see if
I go back here and I'm a curator right
there are actually curators who read
papers and decide ok this paper is
supporting with this kind of evidence
the claim that this protein is involved
in positive regulation of a math kinase
activity but that human is making a
decision and maybe they just called it
regulation of map kinase or maybe they
called it map kinase activity maybe they
didn't get a specific and another person
would get a little more specific they
try to minimize variation but you know
there's still a lot of it so maybe you
don't really want to say do proteins
have exactly the same term maybe you
want to look at similarity of terms and
so then we start looking at distances
and the gene ontology they even talk
about similarity and you could just look
at distances in the graph right we have
a directed acyclic graph you can compute
distance if you assume that the edges
are undirected because you're gonna have
to go up and down right or maybe just
the sum of distances to a common
ancestor right so from a common ancestor
but what's typically done is the
semantic similarity thing right so this
is actually kind of nice because it's
looking at more it's basically saying if
two two functional terms have as their
common ancestor something really high up
the tree like cellular process that's
not very informative I don't care that
much right but if they have something
that's pretty low down and and
meaningful that's a lot more interesting
and so by meaningful I'm going to just
take the negative log of the probability
of seeing that term right so that I can
you know common terms I'm gonna see all
the time right and so they're going to
take for any two terms c1 and c2 we're
gonna look at all the common ancestors
right so we could go if we were up here
we could go up the tree sum up the bag
and find additional common ancestors and
of those what's the least likely one
let's take a negative log of its
probability right so that's how we
assess semantic similarity and we do
this with I mean you can do this with
any source of functional annotation
there are a number of hierarchical
methods like this mips has its own
version of it there are no there are
other ones the organism specific
databases we also get a lot of pathway
data from pathway databases like the bio
site collection and pathway databases or
The Keg collection of pathways so people
use that to some degree as well those
are not typically as hierarchically
organized but some things are
we still don't know protein function
right so all of this you know I sort of
about something like a third of the
unipro of the human proteins in Unipro
don't have any experimental II derived
annotation of the gene ontology they
have a couple of computational things
there are 10 to 15% of human proteins
that even with all the computational
inferences we just have know you know we
can we can look at structure we have no
idea what they do so this isn't getting
us far enough right and you saw a little
bit about using like things like profile
HMMs to talk about what protein family
something might be a good rep hidden
Markov model of a protein family that
fits the data for the sequence but we're
oh you can still you can predict that
something is DNA binding and still not
know what its function is so this is
where we started looking at protein
after action networks as a way of
getting at what proteins do
and the basic idea behind this is really
this sort of guilt by association
concept so this starts out by saying
that if I don't know the function of a
protein but it's connected to a protein
whose function I know maybe I should
assume that they do the same thing right
that sounds very simplistic but in fact
that was sort of the whole the whole
basis of guilt by association is that
that claim and this was the original
example in protein interaction Network
data they use this principle wildly and
other kinds of networks where we had a
protein where we knew that it was
involved in Argentine tabal ISM and we
had a couple of other proteins that were
connected to each other but and to that
protein and we were able to make some
valid dateable claims about their
function based on that so that's well
and good and a lot of protein function
prediction from protein interaction
networks just relies on this principle
is saying okay well if I'm connected to
you then I must have your function or
maybe I have your function but that gets
a little simplistic and it isn't always
true so actually there's a nice paper by
Gillis and Publius that basically says
guilt by association has worked for us
because we're assessing a biased subset
of the graph but it's subject to all
sorts of problems right so so there are
examples look kind of abstracted away
and simplified their examples a little
bit but so you can imagine versions with
more edges but the basic idea is suppose
you're trying to predict the function of
this guy as and this is this gets
generalized to a basically majority of
the functions of the neighbors right so
you look at your whole neighborhood of
all of the proteins are connected to and
you vote that you're going to have the
function that the majority of them have
right so suppose that we're going to
predict a function and our functions are
either green or
orange so we're gonna just predict a
color of neighbor and we don't know
anything about the function of this
protein so we want to predict it well if
we happen to have this edge then we're
gonna predict orange but if we happen to
be missing this edge which we are with
some substantial probability based on
wherever data are coming from and the
fact that all of these things are
incomplete we're gonna not make that
prediction that this is orange where
maybe we should write and similarly
suppose we have this orange but we're
trying to predict the function of this
protein right well maybe this is a green
protein and it's connected to a green
protein and an orange protein so we
would be not sure which which color we
should predict but maybe we're missing
this news in this edge right and then
we're gonna make a mistake we're gonna
say oh this is an orange protein we're
gonna get it wrong right so we get false
positives and false negatives from doing
this and so the argument is that
basically there are certain edges that
are really important in this network for
function prediction and that we've
disproportionately biased our protein
interaction asses towards those edges
right we care about important proteins
we care about hug proteins we look at
their connections they're more likely to
have other neighbors who are in a
complex with them so that there's some
bias here that again this is another one
of these examples of noise where it's
kind of hard to model the noise exactly
but we know that there is some bias and
you can argue you know people do try to
model it right people will try to say
okay here's a model of what the bias
looks like what does that do to our
graphs and some of some of these
arguments are based on um you know
studies like that
so you can be smarter about guilt by
association to one of the things you can
look at is again functional similarity
so you don't have to get the exact same
term you can get an approximate term and
was shown that the closer you are in the
network the more semantic similarity
there is between the annotations that
have been applied to proteins and you
can be a little deeper about that still
right so you can look at the network
neighborhood in general
look at the whole network neighborhood
here I colored these by how far out they
are so let's suppose that I want to look
at everything that's within three hops
from my protein written my red protein
in the center and I'm gonna call that my
neighborhood right so you can do
neighborhood based prediction there was
a neighborhood counting method that was
one of the early methods proposed where
you could just basically look at the
function so let's look at the functions
of all of the things in my network
neighborhood for some neighborhood
distance radius of size K right so maybe
it's just the orange ones that are
within distance one or the orange and
yellow ones and distance two or all
three and then I'm gonna count for all
of those how many of my neighbors have
each annotation terms so five of my
neighbors have mTOR signaling as an
annotation term five of them say DNA
damage checkpoint you know three of them
say nuclear division and so on and I'm
going to rank these and then predict the
top three functions I don't know how
they picked three and I do know how they
picked K which is that they tried a
whole bunch of K and took the best of
them which isn't really an ideal way of
doing it but so you can do a pretty good
job of getting functions right by
looking at something like this but again
if you do cross-validation or with whole
known annotations you get something's
wrong and of course some of your
predictions may be correct and you may
just not know it right so unless you can
actually go back and do experimental
assays to confirm unvalidated
predictions you're not actually going to
know if you're right in some of these
cases I mean one thing you can do is you
could use an old version of the
functional annotation and compare it to
a new one and see if you get new things
correct right so you can you can go and
download go from a particular date or a
particular version and try that
one of the issues with all of this is
that the terms that tend to be most
common right and maybe I need to go find
a slide that shows them add for a minute
but the terms that tend to be the most
common tend to be these terms at the top
of the ontology and they also tend to be
not very informative terms right they
tend to be things like developmental
process or cellular process or
biochemical function or something
so we tend to have annotations that
don't mean a lot and so we'd like to
actually do something
statistical to say let's focus on the
ones that are interesting and meaningful
and you know unexpected right so this
one of the earliest examples of that was
looking at sort of a chi-squared
computation for likelihood of seeing an
annotation term so for each term you can
compute the chi-squared value as being
so let's say you have a certain number
of neighbors of distance K you have ni
neighbors you can see wait how many you
would actually see with term I and then
you can say well okay I have I'm in here
and I have six neighbors and seven
neighbors I guess a distance one and I'd
expect only you know X percent of them
to be to have term I'd based on its
frequency and the whole whole set of
annotated proteins and so you can
compute observed versus expected and
what's most like likely to what's what's
most surprising basically and that did a
better job of function prediction and
also did a better job of getting terms
out that we're actually interesting and
meaningful and again this is a function
of neighborhood size right so you could
start with a neighborhood of size one
you could grow it to a neighborhood of
you know distance to or whatever
so one of the ones that I like that uses
the local neighborhood structure but
does a more interesting job of it is
Stan litovsky and Simon Kashif did
something with Markov random fields but
basically it was almost it was simpler
than I'm than a full Markov random field
model it's basically just a
probabilistic model of saying that you
know what is the probability of my
neighbor having this particular label am
I having this particular label given
that I have a certain number of
neighbors in within distance Kay
and some of them have you know some
fraction I'm sorry so I shouldn't say
distance Kay distance D and K of them
have term t as their label right so the
idea here is that we're gonna start with
if we know your label then you have that
term with probability 1 and if you don't
then we just use the background
probability if you're having that term
and then we iterate we do sort of an
expectation step where we basically use
the expected probability of your having
of you're having that annotation given
that all of your other neighbors have it
or that's that this fraction of your
neighbors have it so they compute this
probability they do a nice sort of
Bayesian formulation of it and I was
actually hoping I'd be able to go
through that in more detail with you
today except that having gone through
the paper in some detail in the last
week or so it's not very clearly
specified exactly how its computed I
believe that they did it right but it's
the sort of thing that I think it's an
ismd paper from a number of years ago
and I think if they'd gone through two
rounds of review they would have put
more details in the paper but the the
basic concept of the model is pretty
pretty clear and the basic you know the
idea of looking at this probability and
then going a couple of steps out and
saying okay let's all simultaneously
assume that my neighbors are right
and now let's try and compute the
probability of my having this label and
then let's do it again now that I assume
that my updated probabilities are
correct is sort of a typical hmm kind of
approach there catches they don't run it
for too many steps because they're
worried about herring off down wrong
paths so they limit the length of this
rather so the number of iterations
rather severely they do get
exceptionally high precision something
on the order of 98% precision in cross
validation tests they recall is limited
but again you don't always know when
you're when you're missing information
so the other family of approaches that
are kind of interesting to think about
are graph theoretic approaches that look
at and cuts so or max flow or min cut in
the graph one of a number of them have
come up with sort of variations on this
idea of finding ways to partition the
graph such that you minimize the number
of interactions that occur between
proteins with different kinds of
annotations right and so you get the
generally I don't know the generalized
multi cut problem which I guess is or
min way multi cut which I guess is an
np-complete problem but they find
approximate algorithms that do a pretty
good job of it I don't know if they
prove optimality bounds on those but
again I I worry frequently so like one
of the themes that comes up in when I
teach computational biology to students
back home is that so many of the
problems we want to solve are have
provable hardness results right so a lot
of the things we're dealing with our
problems where we know we're unlikely to
find let's say a polynomial time
algorithm for any of them but we need to
come up with something and once you're
in that space well okay you can talk
about approximation algorithms but
that's almost
not enough rate it's not enough for me
to say I'm going to approximate
Hamiltonian path within a factor of two
is optimal it's what's important for me
is that does that give me the Assembly
of a graph of a genome that bears any
resemblance to the real thing right and
so you've got to be very careful when
you're doing these optimization problems
that you're you're optimizing the right
thing and that approximately optimizing
that thing is going to work and so here
I think you have a natural way of
testing it which is that we're looking
at predicting protein function for
proteins that aren't annotated and we
can do that you know do some sort of
cross validation approach and look at
how well we're doing it so we can assess
how well we do and many of these
approaches are pretty effective you can
also look at you know again these are
sort of looking at how many immediate
neighbors are connected so you can look
at this is a flow problem as well Mona
Singh and some colleagues had this
approach a number of years ago where I
mean their argument was really that if
you're just looking at the neighborhood
of protein a and you're looking at a
neighborhood of size 2 or 2 hops away
then this neighborhood has three
proteins with this dark annotation term
and the neighborhood of B also has the
area of a here also has three proteins
with the dark annotation term but this
one's a lot closer and much more likely
to be a term of type B's and then you
know these guys over here might be doing
something totally different right so
they used a flow model to basically
capture the idea that you know it isn't
just that there are three neighbors here
it's that they all have to go through
this inflection point or this bottleneck
to get there and that structure somehow
has meaning
so specifically they sort of said well
okay what if we have some for each
annotation term we do this separately we
have a term over here that's been
annotated for each of these three
proteins and we don't know about these
proteins what's the chance that these
guys should have that annotation well
we're going to come up with a flow model
based
on right so they the weights of the
edges are either one or confidence
scores of the interaction so something
less than one probabilities right and
you start out with infinite flow at each
node that's annotated with a particular
term this is the reservoir of of
annotation for term a time zero and zero
value otherwise and then you kind of let
it propagate over time where basically
you're looking at the flow into and out
of each node so the difference between
flow into and out of the node and you
update it so that the fact that there
are three of these guys they still have
to kind of go through this bottleneck
and that restricts how much of the flow
can get down to each of these guys I
mean that does a really nice job of
function prediction as well and beyond
that I mean so there there are a number
of flow related methods but that's
starting to look at more about the local
network structure of the graph right so
now I'm saying not just who's in my
neighborhood but how am I connected to
who's in my neighborhood and ultimately
when we're looking at these questions of
protein function prediction we want to
look at the structure of who's in the
neighborhood and we want to look at the
community structure of the graph in
general right so a lot of the graphs
that we're dealing with have sort of
hierarchical community structure there
may be little clusters and then they're
clustered into bigger clusters or what
we're going to call modules and that is
going to talk a fair bit later today
about how you use modules or how do you
find modules in a graph and modules are
inherently used in function prediction
right so if you're part of the same
module then you're more likely to have
functions that belong to people in your
module basically so what else can you do
to solve these problems I just want to
touch on a couple of the other broad
methods that that people have used
okay right so one of them is we've been
talking about Network neighborhoods of
distance one or two or three maybe
that's the wrong measure of distance
right and this is something that been
alluded to and people talk about a
little bit earlier in the week but right
here's the distant the shortest path
distance between pairs of nodes in a
typical protein interaction graph and
what you'll see is that there are small
numbers of log scale as well I think or
no it's just it's not log scale but it's
it's a tiny fraction of the number of
nodes or edges but what you'll see is
that there are very small number of
things that are direct neighbors a huge
number of things at distance to a huge
number of things at distance three and
most things are within three hops all
right and then there's a little bit of a
tail so distance isn't really tightly
that measure of distance a number of
edges connecting me is a poor measure of
how likely I am to have your function
right and the way to see this is this
concept of you know predicting whether
there's an edge between nodes a and B in
this graph so suppose this is a social
network graph well this is my Facebook
friends graph right and suppose that
this hub over here is Beyonce right the
fact that a and B both are connected to
beyonce tells me really nothing
whatsoever about whether the two of them
have anything else in common
right it's you know friends with
everybody who cares it's not informative
right but if I have a graph like this
where they're only connected through
somebody who doesn't have a lot of other
connections then actually it's much more
likely that a and B are really neighbors
and really and you know for function
prediction right just change being
neighbors to function prediction right
so these guys you know if you have a hub
in common
you might belong to a complex where
you're all doing the same thing or you
might be just interacting with some
regulatory protein that has a lot of
different connections under different
circumstances
and so transferring that adaptation is a
little bit dicey so one thing you can do
is you can redefine distance in a
network to be some sort of diffusion
based distance so you could look at
random walk properties right your
expected time for a random walk to get
from here to here right if it's you know
with 50% probability you do it in two
hops with 50% probability you go back
and you come back and again so a quarter
of the time you'll do it in four writes
here your expected random walk is
actually going to take four hops or
something your expected time to get from
here to here you know most of the time
you're going to be bouncing around all
over this graph before you get here so
it's much much further so if you
redefine distance in a way that captures
random walk time or a hitting time or
diffusion or some measure of this you
improve almost all the distance based
protein function prediction methods
because you're able to make distinctions
between these guys of degree two and it
doesn't mean to agree to anymore so
that's one of the things that we can do
to help you process along another
it's not equivalent because it doesn't
capture longer distance structures but
yes and I mean permit for maybe for the
hub example it'll be close but for
larger structures it isn't so it's close
but you actually have to do something a
little more than that right so the other
thing you can do is you can change what
you're trying to predict right so
instead of saying I want to predict
exactly that you know I have this gene
ontology term or that gene ontology term
maybe you can just look for particular
kinds of functions and then you can do
it in a different way right so one of
the things we looked at was looking at
hubs and whether they have regulatory
roles and it turns out if you look at
their network neighborhood basically if
they're highly you know if they have
high conductivity or it's something it's
it's not exactly the same as clustering
coefficient but it's similar but but
there's some differences as well from
clustering coefficient but if my network
neighborhood is most likely very well
strongly connected I'm probably part of
a complex of things that's doing one
particular function whereas if it
disconnects in an easy way
I'm more likely to be doing different
things in different times and the catch
to all of this is that these are really
these are really essentially random
graphs with different probabilities on
each edge but they're not the same
probability so you can't all of a great
beautiful graph theory about like
erdos-renyi random graphs goes out the
window and it's an open problem for
anybody who cares about this sort of
thing is could you come up with the
expected number of connected components
in a random graph with arbitrary
probability distributions over the over
the individual edges right I think this
is a hard problem I think maybe a better
way of putting it is could you prove a
hardness result about that because I
think it is hard but so we were able to
do some probabilistic things to say that
you know if it's likely a disconnected
graph than that
that gets regulatory function right so
you could also try
also try to predict you know if you're
just if you're gonna be a hub protein or
if you're going to have a particular hub
function right so then we get into this
question that you raised earlier then
maybe I should have put in the earlier
talk about are these things scale-free
right and so there's definitely a lot of
bits of data that say well okay you know
if I'm if I'm a hub I'm more likely to
be essential and I'm more likely to be
lethal and I'm more likely to have
functional annotations just like that
are related to those right some function
that is an essential function so the
early networks look like they're
scale-free but there are a number of
people out there who argue that a lot of
the scale-free appearance of what we see
in the protein interaction databases is
due in part to the fact that we're
missing a lot of data and we're very
biased on what we have right so it's not
really clear if the underlying network
is scale for your if just the data that
we've collected so far our scale free
and you can I'm gonna try to avoid
weighing in too heavily on who's right
on this because I'm still not really
sure but there are some compelling
arguments that you know certainly some
of the individual data sets and some
collection of the data don't fit this
model very well right and so that gets
back to this sort of whole question of
centrality and we Fallot ear
essentiality right if I'm in a scent if
I'm a central hub protein and you knock
me out then I ought to do a lot of
damage and so we clearly have some hub
proteins right I mean the degree
distribution is such that even if we're
under sampling we clearly do have a long
tail of things that have very high
degree whether it fits the linear model
is not clear but it there certainly are
some hubs right so the original results
said well central hub there there are
hub proteins and they're essential
proteins and then some people came back
and said actually you know what maybe
not in our data set but what's really
happening is that degree is correlated
with whether you do a whole lot of
different functions and so we're
starting to see yeah that explains a lot
of this
allottee and essentiality results that
we saw so far and then people argued
further well actually really what we're
seeing with this with the centrality
lethality data is that we're seeing
complexes right and if something is
connected if something is Hubby it's
probably part of a big complex if it's
part of a big complex
it's either highly enriched for being
essential or highly depleted for being
essential depending on what it does and
we're throwing all that data together
and we're not teasing it out and we're
getting this picture that centrality is
it makes you essential but it's really
not right so I think what I want to
pretty close to time what I think I want
you to take away with this from this is
that there's a lot from protein
interaction networks that we can do to
really learn more about protein function
both in very specific invert in more
general ways but it's not only simple
right so you get these nice centrality
the stability rules and it's peuta
pretty power law graphs and then you
start to say wait a minute
you know we're not really looking at the
whole picture what it what happens if we
look at more of it so modeling what
we're missing is an important area that
people could be working in basically
it's important to understand where the
data are coming from it that's why I
spend some time talking about use two
hybrid and methods is that you need to
know where the data are coming from in
order to be able to build realistic
models coming up with good computational
models of the noise is often hard but at
least understanding what it is so that
you can say okay I'm not these are the
parts of my model that I think are are
an oversimplification but I can still
get something useful out of it with this
I think is probably the way to make the
most impact
it'll be about here
questions are as the coffee worn off
perhaps that you have a question so you
mentioned before talking of how you use
the graph or the function pressure and
you mention how you you put you their
edges so how you you can detect these
directions
what about once around the graph what
about you know
Predaking missing links are there any
mental say well here the seems to be
missing big yeah that would be another
talk
but there's a no there are a lot of
approaches for people who have looked at
ways of predicting missing links some of
them structure a graph structure based
many of them you know based on like
protein structure or print or protein
sequence and attempts at predicting
protein structure so yes there are lots
of computational methods I can point you
towards a review that one of my students
wrote of this stuff but you know there
are that was a few years ago so it's
probably been there's probably been more
since then yes yes so predicting protein
protein interactions is a common area I
think it's less exciting now because the
actual experimental data is growing
enough that maybe that's less essential
but you know yes we do I mean we talked
a little about doing prediction from
some of the other tools right then
so let's yeah um so the problem with all
of the efforts to estimate the false
positive and negative rates of
particular experiment you know datasets
usually somebody's new yeast two-hybrid
dataset comes out and then somebody else
what tends to be happening is that labs
are fighting over your data or bad your
data are worse you're right so there's a
lot I don't know how much of it I
believe because of the you know the sort
of tennis match thing that's going on in
there about people trying to hit each
other with stuff um but there have
definitely been methods made to assess
datasets compared to other datasets and
see which ones are more reliable or
which ones are less reliable and I think
basically what's happening is over time
we're getting better at this right so
the newer stuff is tending to be you
know we're starting to fix some of the
bugs and we're getting more reliable as
as we come out and I can't even begin to
talk about the 15 new technologies that
people have started to use that mostly
they're not using on as huge a scale but
some of them are starting to scale up so
there's this bio core method that uses
residents and I don't really understand
how it works I'm not going to go through
yeah but there are a bunch of
technologies that are coming online and
so again I think once people get them
ready for primetime we're gonna start
seeing you know new or larger datasets
from other sources but I really think
it's a it's a temporal thing in yeast we
probably do in human I don't think we're
close right because of kind of context
right yeah that's an interesting
question right so I would rather call it
context specific PPI
in the sense that I mean I don't know of
a lot of people doing specific
experiments with I guess you could take
tumor cells from a patient or something
and try to characterize that although
again they're I think you'd have a hard
time teasing out what's causing ov and
what's a downstream effect of generals
you know chromosomal dysregulation and
cellular dysregulation but but so I
think patient specific protein
interactions are an interesting concept
I would rather say can you look at a
common context and do this and this is
exactly why round I don't think we have
most of the graph for human which is
that there are so many contexts right
yeast has you know I mean there are
there are a bunch of things you can do
the east but it's one cell right so
you're not looking at you know different
tissues and different organisms in
respond and most of the time you know
there's a happy yeast phenotype and an
unhappy used phenotype and all the nasty
things you can do to it are variations
on that unhappiest phenotype so it's
much simpler and I think with with
humans or even you know other
multicellular organisms it gets much
more complicated much more quickly and I
don't think we've captured all of the
kinds of context the developmental
context the you know
dysregulated context or disease states
that we would want to capture so I would
love to see more of that it's definitely
something that you know people have
looked a little bit at individual
relationships in certain contexts more
more I think regulatory than protein
interaction ones but that's that's a
place where we need a lot more
technological development and that's a
place where prediction of interactions
may be useful so not just is this
interaction of possibility but when is
it a possibility why is it a possibility
right but that isn't itself as a protein
function prediction really so you know
it's a piece of the puzzle but it's it's
not I think that's an area that's not
very well populated yet
how much the data regarding the specific
interaction site is included in this
network model
I mean sure the data are getting the
specific interaction what I mean the
site of the protein yeah just about none
right so basically none of the stuff
I've talked about today is dealing with
physically or chemically how is that
interaction happening this part of this
molecule so that is there is work
looking at this it's really more
structure based right but um and and
some of the attempts to predict like in
tera logs can use okay or these
particular sites really but it's it's
pretty but it's been pretty minimal I
think there's room for more going on in
there
right that he returned just up hearing
stop again at 1:30